et pour en parler nous sommes avec hatem
un aphte et essayiste auteur de la
révolution à la restauration où va la
tunisie aux éditions riveneuve bonsoir
bennati merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france sur ce plateau alors avec
l'annoncé de ce gouvernement c'est un
véritable coup de pression sur le
maghreb ou pour vous une opération
plutôt de de communication pour faire de
l'ombre peut-être à l'extrême droite à
sept mois de la présidentielle
quelle est votre vision je pense que
c'est plutôt une décision une décision
électoraliste les gens ne sont pas dupes
on est à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
on a des rup tion d'un acteur qui d'eric
zemmour pour ne pas le niveau pour ne
pas le citer pour le panneau mais qui
qui monomaniaque sur 7 sur cette
question qui parle tout le temps de la
d'immigration d'islam d'immigration du
stade elle sera la marine le pen au ciel
et marine le pen qui est obligé de
suivre il a ringardisé toute la glace
toute la classe politique qui s'est mis
à la droite de toute cette classe
politique en
forçant en tout cas du centre gauche
même du printemps républicains jusqu'à
l'extrême droite dure il a forcé tout
toute cette partie du spectre politique
à le suivre donc c'est clairement
quelque chose de politiciens d'autant
qu'
il ya un chiffre qui est pas mal circulé
aujourd'hui qui est le taux de
reconduite aux frontières des ca d
exécution des obligations de quitter le
territoire français qui a circulé qui
est de 0 2% pour les algériens
je pense que ça fait partie de la
stratégie gouvernementale
il faut juste rappeler que l'algérie a
fermé ses fruits ce taux là ne concerne
que la période entre entre juin et
juillet et précisément surtout cette
période avait pas de liaisons aériennes
quasiment pas de liaisons aériennes
entre paris et alger par exemple donc
c'est généralement sur des vols
commerciaux qu'ont
qu'on exécute les renvoie là
il renvoie à la frontière donc là on est
plus sûr du cerveau du symbolique est
aussi quelque chose qui sent pas très
bon le choix des fois des trois pays
maghrébins c'est voilà on va vous
débarrasser des arabes si vous permettez
l'expression c'est aussi comme ça que
c'est compris il yad'autres ya d'autres
nationalités qui sont qui sont concernés
par les problèmes de migration on
focalise on voit là on donne des gages à
son électorat pour leur dire voilà on va
pas exécuter sa et surtout on ne voit
pas dans quel on n'a pas spécifié en
tout cas comment cette décision va être
exécuté il sera intéressant de voir si
ça va concerner que ça concerne
absolument étudiants il ya l'humoriste
alors que les travailleurs qualifiés est
ce qu'on doit se passer des travailleurs
qualifiés je ne le pense pas c'est on va
continuer dans ce rapport de force entre
le nord et le sud pour rappel en est
dans une relation totalement asymétrique
que un citoyen français n'a pas du tout
besoin d'eux voilà autant de démarches
pour aller s'installer où il veut et
voilà c'est une entrave à la liberté de
la circulation et qui opère dans un seul
sens il serait vraiment intéressant de
voir comment va appliquer ça qui est ce
qu'on va en voir est-ce qu'on va limiter
le regroupement familial si on va
s'interdire de recevoir des étudiants ce
sera intéressant de voir comment on
aussi ça peut être tout simplement de
l'affichage alors le gouvernement en
tout cas parle lui d'une décision
inédite et il dit en qui durcit ton
parce que c'est une sorte de réponse
parce que dit il ces pays du maghreb ne
reprendrait pas leurs ressortissants
expulsés
est-ce que ça c'est une un argument vous
entendez aussi d'ailleurs pourquoi ces
pays du maghreb ne reprennent pas les
expulser en france est-ce que ça
calmerait le jeu peut-être
justement et qui est un geste aussi de
ces pays là alors juste avant de venir
j'ai consulté un rapport parlementaire
donc qui tient d'une instance étatique
qui date de 2018 parce que encore une
fois il ne sert à rien de faire des
comparaisons avec 2020 et 2021 on était
encore vide donc ce n'est pas
intéressant
alors certes ces trois pays sont
au nombre important de
leurs concitoyens qui se voient délivrer
une des obligations de quitter le
territoire français le taux d'exécution
est au tour entre 43% pour la tunisie
est à peu près de 50% pour l'algérie et
le maroc on voit que la réduction
concerne la verse donc les tunisiens
sont moins pénalisé que les deux autres
que les deux autres nationalités mais il
ya d'autres pays qui ont des taux
similaires par exemple l'egypte a aussi
un taux d'exécution d'à peu près la
moitié et l'egypte récupère justement le
taux d'exécution j'entends par là les
citoyens qui sont effectivement
éloignées du territoire donc à peu près
le même taux entre l'egypte l'algérie le
maroc je note aujourd'hui que
qu'on va sanctionner les pays maghrébins
et pas les pays et j'y tiens et je pense
que derrière il ya aussi un enjeu
géopolitique les relations tendues entre
alger et paris pour ça on va dire ça un
classique et a eu la sphère pegasus avec
le maroc est sans doute ce qui se passe
en tunisie
motive aussi ceux qui cette décision
gouvernementale je ne pense pas que ce
soit juste le critère de reconduite ou
non à la frontière donc encore une fois
il ya d'autres pays qui sont à ces
niveaux-là d'exécution des oqtf et qui
n'ont pas été sanctionnées donc pour
vous pas forcément le fond du problème
cet argument brandi par le gouvernement
il y a un aspect électorale mais aussi
peut être une excuse c'est ça il selon
vous pour moi il ya deux choses il ya
l'aspect électoral
il est clair et net comme quoi personne
n'est dupe et il y a
comme partout à chaque fois qu'il s'agit
de dénis de diplomatie il ya des
rapports de force à naître aujourd'hui
la france n'est pas au beau fixe avec
ces trois pays et
elle préfère voilà mettre cette menace à
exécution mettre la pression certes sur
ces pays là encore une fois on est dans
un rapport qui est totalement
dissymétrique est épargné d'autres pays
je prends juste le cas de l'egypte ce
n'est pas du tout le seul qui qui
expulse enfin dont on expulse à peu près
20 qui qui qui acceptent de récupérer à
peu près la moitié de ses concitoyens
qui se sont vu
signifier une obligation de quitter le
territoire français aujourd'hui
clairement la france peut-elle se
permettre une potentielle crise
diplomatique avec ces trois pays alors
que vous venez de le préciser les
relations sont pas vraiment au beau fixe
oui tout à fait on est encore là on est
dans la diplomatie on a vu pour prendre
un tout autre exemple on a vu un
problème beaucoup plus important qui est
là faire des sous marins on a vu comment
la france est rentrée dans le rang au
bout d'une semaine et pour autant le
problème n'a pas été résolu en tout cas
au bénéfice de la france quand enfin en
matière de diplomatie c'est toujours les
rapports de force qui prime aujourd'hui
paris s'estime en voilà en position de
force pour imposer
ses règles à ces trois anciennes
colonies merci beaucoup à thème la fille
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre point de vue ce soir merci à vous